Hey it's me Destin,
welcome back to Smarter Every Day.
So I'm gonna share something with you that's so sweet
you might actually cry, because I did the first time I saw it.
There's this little girl in Ohio who saw the
Project for Awesome video I made last year for
Not Forgotten, which is an orphanage we work with in Peru
and I make a video about it every December,
and she saw the video and instead of just donating
like we usually do, you know we see something on the internet
and like oh yeah I'll click the button, or I'll whatever,
I'll.. couple of bucks here, whatever.
She actually did something about it.
Like so she saw it and she decided to take action on her own.
For something called her compassion project.
I don't know what that is, but it's pretty amazing.
So what I'd like to do is show you Savannah's video,
her dad gave me permission to do that,
and then after that we will just show you what our reaction
to her video was.
Hi, my name is Savannah,
and I'm in second grade.
Each kid in my class was assigned a compassion project
and here's mine.
My dad and I watch a YouTube channel called Smarter Every Day.
Through that we learned about an organization called Not Forgotten.
Not Forgotten is building an orphanage in Peru to help boys
who have been abandoned.
Peru is in South America.
When I heard about this, I told my dad we needed to do something.
I decided to try and raise money to help them
build an orphanage. My goal was $100.
During christmas break I talked to lots of people about Not Forgotten
and asked them to help me meet my goal.
[music]
Everyone was VERY generous. I raised four times my original goal.
Together we raised $469.
I was so excited to get home to make the donation.
This will make a big difference for the boys in Peru.
It might even save a boy's life.
Thank you so much to everyone who helped me meet my goal.
Right now we are in Iquitos Peru, you can see by the motor cars,
and we're gonna use the money that Savannah came up with
which was $1400 soles,
and we're gonna use it for the orphans.
It's pretty awesome.
We're gonna buy beds.
(Destin) What you got?
- So, turns out 1450 soles pay for those 5 mattresses for that first room.
Savannah that's the exact amount of money you raised for us last year
so we're gonna go ahead and get these mattresses,
take them out to our first house the boys are gonna use to sleep in.
- Sweet.
- Mucho gracias.
- Yeah.
Savannah, this is awesome.
Let's go show you the mattresses, we'll fast forward in time
and show you the mattresses in the building.
Wowwwww!
Alright, come on.
These are 5 beds that we purchased with money that you raised.
Got some pillows, it's a really big deal Savannah, you did that.
A lot of people last year have really big fancy jobs and they
didn't do anything near as cool as that, so thank you
for your compassion project and this is the president
of Not Forgotten. He wants to thank you too.
- Thank you Savannah, that was awesome.
- Savannah, that was awesome.
Thank you so much. Please tell your dad I said you get to stay up late tonight.
[laugh] I'm just kidding.
Also tell him thank you for making that video for us,
we really appreciate it.
For everybody else like me watching this video,
please check out the links in the video description.
You can help Not Forgotten like Savannah did.
She didn't just click the share something on Facebook,
she actually did something, and if you don't want
to help out Not Forgotten, just help out the
charity of your choice.
It's a good thing. Let's just make the world more awesome.
Anyway I'm Destin, you're getting Smarter Every Day.
Have a good one.